what is the null hypothesis should we
expect that Male inside male and female
psychology is the same in every single
respect or other differences and if
there are differences then perhaps one
sex may have an advantage over the other
and in chess it appears empirically to
be men because men tend to dominate
the evidences is that women are
underrepresented in chess and that
alongside open competition which men and
women which everybody can join in
alongside open competition it's been
felt appropriate to put on competitions
just for women
now if you allow trans women to join in
those competitions then you're allowing
a group of males a group of men if you
want to say that to take part in those
competitions which I think just negates
the whole purpose of having that comfort
that separate competition